[Music]
[Applause]
please be seated
good morning welcome welcome to this
recognition ceremony for 139 members of
the 2018 EMBO New York friday-saturday
class 120 members of the 2018 EMBO New
York Saturday class 37 members of the
Americas class give yourselves a round
of applause you are three extraordinary
classes and an extraordinary diverse
group you represent many industries and
backgrounds from finance and technology
health care to consulting media and
marketing you call 33 countries home
from Cameroon Canada and Colombia to
Ireland Israel and India you speak more
than 27 languages including Hindi
Hungarian Tamil Urdu and I am told
English you are incredibly accomplished
more than a quarter of you came into
this program with at least another
advanced degree under your belt and
among you you will find a ballet dancer
a professional football player a surfer
a model an actor and entrepreneurs
adventurers and philanthropist of every
strike now perhaps some of the most
talented of you are the parents in this
class
[Applause]
in this day before Mother's Day I would
note that an impressive 27 of you
welcome to child during your time in the
program vo and let's not forget about
spouses and partners and children and
loved ones who have supported you
through residence suites international
seminars and weekends in the library 17
have you tied the knot during the
program 22 more of you got engaged
congratulations
now it has been particularly gratifying
for all of us to see how you exemplify
things we all hold dear about this
school you are bright talented committed
to principles of leadership and
entrepreneurial thinking and you're
committed to one another I know I could
tell you 296 success stories about
today's graduates one of them is Brooke
Jones Chinetti who with six years six
years of military experience and two
deployments in the Middle East under her
belt found herself missing the community
of strong intelligence service members
that she was part of before coming back
to civilian life so recognizing that
more than half of transitioning female
veterans found the process to be more
difficult than anticipated
she started your sequel a network and
mentorship platform that helps
transition female vets with women
leaders from the industries in which
they're pursuing a career with your
sequel Brooke is redefining mentorship
for these vets and I'm confident there's
nothing but success in her future
Meredith Shields had a transition of her
own during the program moving
moving from her role as a nurse
practitioner to the world of Pharma it
was an unexpected and welcome change
inspired by coursework in the core and
electives in pharmaceutical marketing
she discovered she could bring her
skills and interests as a practitioner
to another field within the healthcare
industry and starting next summer
she'll be honing her new interests in a
development program at Regeneron best of
luck Meredith now a few of your
classmates also add journeys that took
unexpected turns bill Irvine made a
u-turn when after arriving for the
program with the intent of joining an
investment team found himself instead
co-founding and launching carbon sole a
clean tech startup his friend a Columbia
engineering students applied the
business model as classmate served as
sounding boards and his professors the
Lange Center and the tamers Center all
served as advisors and mentors as he
worked toward launch with a mission to
produce complex chemicals that can be
used in common fashion and home goods
using waste negative technology that
impacts positively the environment bill
and carbon sole just to comb 10,000
bucks at the launch our competition his
team also secured one of three
qualifying spots to compete in the
Department of Energy's clean tech
University prize where they'll be
competing for an additional hundred
thousand dollar grant Congrats no doubt
we'll be hearing more now many of you
took tremendous leaps in your current
careers or leaps of faith into new ones
with the encouragement of her classmates
Roenick Trivedi will go from the Army to
Estee Lauder after she graduates that's
kind of a transition Jean Cole middle
went all-in on launching a start-up on
point a travel travel planning platform
that personalizes and consolidates
recommendations tips and itineraries
based on them
graphics and interests and networks and
hosannah and czar Azari he surprised
himself when two months into the program
he became co-founder in chief data
scientist of clarity money an app that
helps more than a million users across
the United States make better financial
decisions just just just last month the
app was acquired by Goldman Sachs
a move I'm certain makes a great deal of
sense including cen TS now finally many
of you forged relationships that have
been both personally and professionally
rewarding Joe Schwartz and dagger a
Olson became partners in a joint private
equity venture that's already well on
its way to success and Amanda raposo and
Courtney Barnaby took their passion for
fun and families and affordable
childcare to launch project playdate
with a growing network of families and
funding project playdate is poised to be
a successful and scalable model for
childcare across the nation Congrats to
all of you
since the day that you all arrived all
of us on faculty and staff have
challenged you to be active and
contributing members of the community I
can assure you and your guests that you
have more than met this challenge as
students and I know you will continue to
do so as you join 45,000 CBS alums
around the world that community is more
important to you than ever and the
personal and professional relationships
that you have forged at Columbia will
form the foundation of that lifelong
membership in the CBS community now I
look I know you've learned a lot here
but I just want to focus on two things
that a great Business School can impart
your MBA is a calling card that says to
the world
I'm entrepreneurial I'm a problem solver
I understand the whole puzzle not just a
piece of it and I know how to seize upon
opportunity in any environment that's
the first big thing
the second important mark a great
program should and this one does prepare
you for a lifelong career in business in
social enterprise for some of you
perhaps even public service for all of
you what that means is not just a skill
set but a mindset that will enable you
to succeed and because you already know
more than some less experienced MBAs
about what you expect from your careers
you know that the value of your degree
and experience will unfold over a
lifetime now your graduating from the
Business School in a period of really
exciting opportunity and change in the
world of business and you no doubt do so
with a greater perspective on cycles the
curriculum you have experienced that
Columbia is really focused with you on
trying to grab an opportunity in any
environment or cycle and thanks to the
school's position here in New York
you've benefited from unrivaled access
to myriad industries and visionary
business leaders the reputation and
strength of this school and your program
has equipped you with what you need to
succeed combined with your own great
abilities as an alum CBS will provide
you with the connections and support to
foster creativity invite your
entrepreneurial thinking and open doors
the opportunity these tools will help
give you the confidence and ability to
succeed on your terms and you couldn't
be better prepared but I have to say to
you this morning as well that with the
rewards of your MBA come responsibility
what does it really mean to be a
graduate of Columbia Business School I
hope we hope and expect that you recall
that we are and always have been in the
business of both value and values yes we
are proud to be the birthplace of value
investing and we strive to add value in
all disciplines but we also recognize
and are ajudar know that personal values
matter a lot in the marketplace so as
you rise in your career remember your
courses and discussions and leadership
and ethics which I hope help you inspire
others who work with you I hope you
recognize your role as proud stewards of
the CBS brand and that you both tap into
and add value to the community so what's
gonna happen this morning in one sense
the familiar sense you'll graduate you
will become part of the school's alumni
network throughout the world and like so
many grads before you you're gonna make
your mark in the world I know you're
gonna be inspired by your predecessors
like Gerry spire or Lee Cooperman or
Henry Kravis Roberts Smith Russ Carson
Warren Buffett Mario gabelli Vikram
Pandit James Gorman John Martin and Tim
compost or any of 45,000 names I could
rattle off that community belongs to you
it's an esse you should leverage it over
your lifetime but you know what on days
like this and everybody talks about
graduate I prefer a
or old-fashioned term commencement
because it makes an explicit reference
to both beginnings and transitions
you're going to continue a life of
engagement in business and society and
as you leave here remember that the
value of your MBA experience will unfold
over time what I look forward to hearing
from you in the years ahead is what you
didn't expect but God anyway from the
program and your degrees I'm looking
forward to hearing what this mindset
will give you your company and our world
but if there's one thing not to forget
never forget what a noble calling
business is and the power that lies
within each and every one of you this
morning to transform lives of other
business leaders and entrepreneurs along
with communities and nations around the
world remember that your MBA you should
think of as a master of choices what
matters most of all of us is not the
change jingling in your pockets after
commencement but the change you will
make in the world give yourselves a
round of applause and congratulations
it is now my pleasure to turn the
microphone over to Kellie Martin Blanco
Kellie
Thank You Dean Hubbard's you all look
fabulous
congratulations can't wait to celebrate
tonight I said you'll look even better
tonight and somebody commented well at
least at first good one the Executive
MBA commitment to excellence award was
established by the MBA class of 1991 in
memory of Professor margaret ka chandler
it's presented to a faculty member for
contributions to the class commemorating
the high standards set by professor
Chandler for the Embera Marika's class
this year's recipient is Donna Hetrick
Donna currently serves as senior
lecturer of finance director of the
private equity program and a Sanford C
Bernstein Center for leadership and
ethics faculty leader at Columbia
Business School her courses include
corporate finance business law mergers
and acquisitions and advance corporate
finance she's been nominated for the
Dean's Award for innovation in the MBA
curriculum for her advanced corporate
finance course and is a six-time
recipient of this award the Executive
MBA commitment to excellence award prior
to Donna's positions at Columbia she had
a long successful career in investment
banking and was a corporate lawyer she
received her MBA from Columbia Business
School prior to that she received BS and
JD degrees from st. John's University
and she is also a New York state
certified paramedic
so please welcome and congratulate Donna
Hetrick
[Applause]
well good morning and thank you I wish
you could have seen what I saw coming in
it was the only time I saw embas moved
slowly but it's as calm as Dean Blanco
said I'm a proud graduate of Columbia
Business School I'm in 1990 alum and as
I've said many times I'm totally in awe
of the embassy and I'm very very
fortunate I'm grateful to be here I'm
grateful that I knew professor Chandler
my graduate as I said 90 and I had a
class an opportunity to take a class
that she and Bill Klepper taught called
interpersonal dynamics and I echo what
Dean Hubbard said about how important it
is to have values and one of the things
I've always appreciated about the embas
is your ability to work together as a
team I've always said embas can take any
hill and take it well so I just wanted
to thank you today for letting me be
part of your life for making me be a
very blessed person to get up every day
and do something that I love to do not
many people can say they do that and I
can honestly say I do that and I thank
you for allowing me to be here full time
at Columbia it's when the Ambo program
really started to take off that I was
fortunate enough to be able to get a
full-time job here so I'm grateful for
that
and I also want to share with you
something that you may or may not know
which were you were my inspiration to
become a paramedic I had been an EMT for
many years and I've been always kicking
around in the back of my mind that I
wanted to go further I wanted to take
that next step and I thought to myself
how on earth am I going to be able to go
to class three nights a week and I
figured well that's only 12 hours the
embas go every weekend for 16 and then I
thought about all the rotations I had to
do on the ambulances or in the o.r or
you know in the different places in the
hospital and I thought well they go all
in those international seminars now we
will say rotations in the ER are not
quite an international seminar but but
it did take a lot of time and I can't
tell you how many times I thought of you
guys and you inspired me because there
are days that as much as I love doing
what I do when the one train is going
this way and it's stopping here and you
got to take a bus and all that stuff I
think about you guys and sometimes I
feel like I should get credit just
because I showed up right
you do more than show up you do more
than show up every single day you've
been a blessing in my life and I'll
leave you with one one small thought
which is I saw a t-shirt here many years
ago and I think my husband Tom stole it
and what it did was made by one of the
classes and it had everybody's name in
the class on the back and it said ember
doing more after midnight than most
people do all day so thank you very much
for giving me this honor and
congratulations
Thank You Donna it's now my pleasure
this morning to introduce Amanda raposo
who is chosen by the Americas class to
speak today amanda is the founder of
project playdate a marketplace for safe
social and stimulating childcare
experiences supporting children in the
cultivation of joy curiosity and
meaningful connection after graduating
from NYU in 2011 with a BA in social
work Amanda realized she needed to learn
a thing or two about business as an
embassy served on the Lange Center for
Entrepreneurship Student Advisory Board
and as a teaching assistant for the
leaders voice course amanda is the
recent first prize winner of the
university-wide columbia venture
competition and is currently working out
of the Columbia startup lab to scale her
company please join me in congratulating
and welcoming
Amanda Raposo to the stage
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning Dean Hubbard esteemed
faculty fellow students friends and
family business students are evil
business students are evil was the first
line of my application to Business
School and somehow Columbia still let me
in what were you thinking
let me explain my background is in
social work and business is evil was a
common belief shared in that space those
in business many thought are creating
all of the problems that we were trying
to fix now of course I went on to say
that this notion is not only false but
also damaging to our collective ability
in making the world a better place
luckily the person who read my
application shared my strange sense of
humor and let me in business students
are evil was the first myth that I
debunked by pursuing Business School now
that we're done here are four more myths
that I'd like to shed some light on myth
number one cBS students are here because
of their wealth and privilege my italian
grandfather made it to New York as a
stowaway on a boat my Portuguese father
made it to New York after two young
siblings passed away due to a lack of
basic health care on his Island grandpa
and dad knew no English
they had no wealth or formal education
yet their resilience gave me every
opportunity to pursue my dreams I see a
version of this family story and so many
of my peers and in their families from
around the world you have moved
mountains to make it here maybe so that
one day your kids could pursue their own
dreams dear friends I'm humbled and
inspired by you every day myth number
two business students
we care about money this couldn't be
further from the truth the most
consistent core drivers behind each
person I've met in this program have
more to do with the desire to create
opportunity for their loved ones a
personal legacy a vision for a different
and better world okay and maybe a few
extra bucks myth number three full-time
students are smarter than Emma's
students
okay full-time when you have someone in
your program like David Kim a successful
serial entrepreneur who has started his
own private equity firm or Barrett
captain in the US Army now director of
operations at Citigroup or Brenda CSO of
her family business and Mexico and mom
of three then maybe you can consider
spreading such a ridiculous rumor I
invite you full timers to challenge me
on this one and I would be more than
happy to elaborate last but not least
myth number four
cBS students spend most of Business
School partying this one might be true
but hey we call it networking so now
that we've debunked these myths how do
we look towards the future let's start
with a simple truth nobody got here
alone and we all came here to better
ourselves and the world around us last
summer I co facilitated the penn
columbia social impact house we brought
together 30 high-performing social
entrepreneurs to a remote farm in
Vermont so that they could recenter when
they left at the end of the week feeling
inspired and empowered
there was a farewell sign in the
driveway that said it could always be
like this
now we may not always be able to sit in
a class on accounting and learn about
purple markers thanks professors if but
what can we but we can still honor an
intention to cultivate change and the
people who got us here so then what
about this transformative experience can
we carry with us into our next chapter
well that relationships are everything
there's absolutely nothing more powerful
or important than investing your time
and presence and the people around you
it was such a gift to take time out of
each month to focus on gaining knowledge
and self-awareness this doesn't have to
stop today we can keep reading keep
exploring new skills let us stay cure
and continue to challenge the status quo
Amba enhanced our abilities in ways we
might not even have anticipated ambition
combined with a refined set of skills
enables each of us to achieve great
influence in the work that we do
business is not evil but that's only if
people like us continue to push forward
with integrity in our own areas of
expertise it is not just our privilege
but our responsibility finally even when
the pressures of balancing school and
work and family were sometimes
unbearable we all carved out time to
seek adventure and have a whole lot of
fun together it could always be like
this connection curiosity ambition and
joy I wish this with my whole heart for
each of you and I can cannot wait to
hear about all of the ways that you
change the world for the better
you have certainly already changed mine
and I couldn't be more grateful and on
behalf of my classmates I'd like to
extend this gratitude to all of our
mother's father's grandparents partners
friends children mentors from our past
and in our present who have made so many
sacrifices so that each and every one of
us could sit here right now thank you
with the resilience of those that came
before us and the support of all of you
sitting with us today we've accomplished
the things that our ancestors have only
dreamt of
congratulations friends and thank you
[Applause]
for the M Bannu York Saturday class
this year's Executive MBA commitment to
excellence award recipient is Professor
Paul Ingram Paul Ingram is the Kravis
professor of Business at Columbia
Business School and the faculty director
of the Columbia advanced management
program Columbia's flagship program for
senior executives from around the globe
additionally he consults with leading
companies across industries on
organizational design and strategy his
research on organizations worldwide has
been widely published and has been
recognized with numerous awards and
distinctions Paul's undergraduate degree
is from Brock University where he
received the Governor General's Award as
the top graduating student and later
received the distinguished graduate
award from Brock's Faculty of Business
his PhD is from Cornell University and
he served on the faculty at Carnegie
Mellon University before joining us here
at Columbia at Columbia Business School
Paul has received the deans award for
Teaching Excellence as well as the
Executive MBA commitment to excellence
awards from six graduating member
classes please join me in congratulating
Professor Ingram once again and
receiving this prestigious distinction
[Applause]
thank you I'm thrilled to get this award
from cluster ZM and clusters BN a you
didn't vote for me so I am you're about
to become MBAs the world will see you as
captains of industry masters of the
market you'll be expected to dominate
your companies and crush your rivals but
when I look at you I don't see
conquerors I see children but not only
because not only because some of you
threw tantrums when you arrived this
morning and discovered there wasn't an
omelet station really I mean this
comparison as a compliment to you in
fact I seem that see the same two great
qualities and members of this class that
I see in my own two daughters let me
tell you first about my older daughter
Alexandra on the first day of school in
the fall this year she came home with a
newly issued school computer and a
homework assignment to do geology
exercise using an app on that computer
it turns out that the computer hadn't
been set up correctly and she couldn't
access the app so she couldn't do the
assignment well we tried to install the
app but we couldn't figure it out we
emailed the teacher but we didn't get a
response so eventually I told her that
this was the type of thing that happens
on the first day of school and everybody
would understand it would be worked out
the next day so she went to bed and so
did I an hour later she came into my
room in distress and she woke me up
I was afraid there was some kind of
health emergency but what had upset her
so much was that she hadn't been able to
complete her homework at the age of
eleven she already took her assignment
her responsibilities so seriously that
she couldn't sleep without completing
them that example helps me to understand
you it helped me particularly to be
patient when I got xx email from members
of this class asking you how to find
something on canvas
I know that the students in this class
cared deeply about meeting their
responsibilities that they are care
about doing the right things for their
companies their communities and their
families clusters be an a I'll give you
the benefit of the doubt on this
but next time vote for me my younger
daughter Amanda is five years old almost
six in the last couple of months Amanda
has been learning to play chess and she
seems to have a knack for it in her
chess class at the end of every session
they have a tournament a competition in
the first three weeks of class she won
each tournament I went to pick her up
from the fourth class session a fourth
week of class and the chess master comes
up to me with a concerned look on his
face and he says we have to talk and he
says to me
Amanda won again we have to do something
about this well I was infuriated and I
let him know it I told him how sick I
was of this culture of punishing success
and that I knew the game of chess and
there was no way to play it without
allowing for the possibility that
somebody was going to win well I was a
few minutes into this diatribe when he
stopped me and he said the problem
wasn't that Amanda was winning it was
what she did when she won it turns out
when she wins she does a victory dance
she's been known to moon her opponent
apparently that isn't done in chess who
knew but anyway
Amanda reminds me of this class also I
know that you love to win and revel in
success that's admirable too so what I
really mean when I say that I think of
you as children is that in my mind you
represent the best in all of us
a commitment to do the right thing
combined with a love of winning and that
as children those fine qualities are
very close to the surface in members of
this class I'd like to leave you with an
idea about how as you go forward you can
combine these two great qualities on
July 16th 2016 we talked in class about
the fact that people are happiest when
they're pursuing a dream and that
actually achieving a dream is a mixed
blessing because it can leave you Amos I
suggested that if you ever achieved a
dream you should savor it for a weekend
and then on Monday identify a new
aspiration I can tell you now that when
I gave you that message in your first
semester I was actually thinking forward
to this graduation day you've achieved
something fabulous
even you BNA you have won and you
deserve the chance to do your victory
dance enjoy this weekend with your
family and friends and be proud of
yourselves as I'm proud of all of you
but don't wallow in your success
come Monday mornings start thinking
about the next great thing that you're
going to achieve and make it something
worthy of you something that reflects
your drive to meet your responsibilities
and to do the right thing Robert Louis
Stevenson wrote that it is better to
travel hopefully than to arrive that is
my hope for you that you travel
hopefully and I'm so grateful to be here
to see you begin your journeys thank you
and congratulations
[Applause]
it is now my distinct pleasure to
introduce rocky gran ahem as you might
have surmised she was chosen by her
fellow students to be the graduation
speaker for the Amba New York Saturday
class so let me tell you a little bit
about rocky rocky gran ahem is a senior
vice president and Oppenheimer funds
leading the institutional relationship
management team for her clients invested
in global equity strategies she has been
with Oppenheimer funds for 24 years
based out of their New York City office
she graduated from my own a college with
a BA in marketing
she was born in Quezon City Philippines
and immigrated to the United States
moving to the Bronx with her family when
she was four years old she was the first
in her family to graduate from college
and is minutes away from being the first
in her family to graduate with an MBA
she lives with her husband Dennis and
her two sons Riley and Owen in Lincroft
New Jersey please join me in
congratulating and welcoming rocky
granite
[Applause]
so to make sure you can see me I just
have to do one more thing is that better
well good morning Dean Hubbard Dean
Blanco distinguished faculty family
friends and to the 2018 Saturday embas I
was hoping you'd do that okay my name is
rocky grant Han and on behalf of the
Saturday embas I want to acknowledge our
families who have supported our journey
and I would especially like to thank my
husband Dennis who has held our family
together for the past two years and my
two sons Riley and Owen who have been
terrifically patient and understanding
and I hope the three of you don't mind
that you get all of my energy and focus
back every Saturday going forward our
class would also like to thank the
office of student affairs especially
felicia goodman and christina Montville
who guided us through this adventure
answered every email and there were
never any complaints so today is a
special day but for me it's not as
specialists tomorrow which is Mother's
Day including me there are a total of
five Amba moms Diana
Simone Connie and Marge on beginning
tomorrow will be the first day we can
celebrate Mother's Day without the worry
of homework for the past two years and
I'd like to wish all of the mothers and
grandmothers here today and those in
heaven a very happy Mother's Day
in addition to the M bombs I want to
applaud the 18 member dads we survived
and we thrived we leaned off we fed off
each others energy and leaned on each
other for support believing in the
importance of showing our kids that to
stay curious and whether you're a parent
or not we all share the same belief that
you're never too old to learn something
new so I have a challenge for you today
I can't leave you without one challenge
I want you to think about if it's not
you then who if it's not you then who I
took this challenge with my Amba
experience M before me was about
overcoming my fears and eliminating
regret 20 years ago
I chose love instead of an MBA and I
don't regret that decision in fact love
is at the top of my values hierarchy and
I have a beautiful family as a reward
for that great decision but there's been
this gnawing in my gut and this voice in
my head that has kept telling me you're
not good enough just yet and your best
days are yet to come
so April 22nd 2016 was our first day of
orientation and on that day you may have
thought you met a confident woman on the
outside but some of you might know I was
a hot mess on the inside I was fierce at
came over me sitting in that auditorium
looking around at all of you all
hundred-and-twenty successful
professionals representing 20 different
countries and family and friends they
speak over 30 languages and yes
English was one of them we had an Emmy
winner in rich am singer we had Simone
Lewis as our America's Next Top Model
finalist we had yeah we had
entrepreneurs and more and I scared
myself
even more knowing that most of you had
better knowledge of excel functions than
I had
you did um I know it seems silly but I
sat there in the room in awe and I just
asked myself can I build relationships
with such a diverse group of people
could I survive and keep up with them
and will I fit in then the voice of my
high school principal sister Mary Ellen
came through with a better question in
my head
she said she taught me the importance of
resilience sacrifice and to let my voice
be heard she would say to me you've got
the tools and skills so if you don't do
it who will if it's not you to take on
the challenge than who if it's not you
then who
I witnessed numerous examples of our
classmates taking on the challenge if
it's not you then who at Columbia
Business School matters and for those of
you who are not familiar with Columbia
Business School matters we refer to it
as CBS matters and it's a it's a ten
minute presentation given by students to
share their background and their goals
and in the storytelling it demonstrated
that we were actually more alike than
different so one of the most powerful
stories I remember from CBS matters came
from marjan Dean marjan Dean slayed the
challenge if it's not you then who
she's our class example of resilience
she became a mother at a very young age
and a judgment was questioned by those
closest to her but putting aside her
feelings of being overwhelmed and alone
she made the decision she said nobody
else could be a better mother to that
child than her she not only graduated
from college with an infant in tow she
went on to become an engineer earned her
first master's degree in information
sciences is a tech executive whose
minutes away from earning her first her
MBA she took baskets of lemons and made
lemonade living her happily ever after
with love and support from her husband
and
another powerful CBS matters moment of
accepting the challenge if it's not you
then who is a story about sacrifice and
that was told during our first residency
weekend
Jordan frame was deployed to Iraq we're
doing a routine road stop he and his
troops found themselves in
life-threatening combat leaving him
unconscious when he came to his
protective instincts came through and
which resulted in saving many lives
jordan is a decorated US military
veteran who was awarded a Purple Heart
and a Bronze Star with valor
[Applause]
in addition to Jordan frein accepting
the challenge if it's not you then who
I'd also like to acknowledge all of our
US military veterans Teresa ha
Jessica Hutton Craig Glebe Ric miles
Curt Schwab and Ori shainsky we all
thank you for the sacrifices you made to
our country my final example of a cohort
taking on the challenge if it's not you
then who is known as our most
overzealous class participant I know you
know who it is and you can say a lot of
things about Kyle Moran's approach but
but but if you allowed yourself to get
beyond that point you would understand
you would understand that he was
demonstrating the importance of letting
your voice be heard he showed us the
importance to let the other party know
to make room for one more idea he willed
his voice to be heard and at the end of
the day he went from negotiating every
single one of us in class to negotiating
one of the biggest deals in Major League
Baseball
well done Kyle
[Applause]
and I leave you with one final thought
because mother knows best the past two
years have been our journey of
stretching beyond the comfort of the sea
of sameness we experienced inner growth
and some of us achieved inner peace to
confidently say yes I am more than good
enough however if you feel that your
calling has yet to arrive it's okay
be open and have courage clarity allows
us to see the challenges that lie ahead
so that you can answer the calling and
the challenge if it's not you then who a
Columbia Business School MBA is a badge
of honor that I wear with you proudly to
remind us that we are at the very center
of business I was very moved when I
learned that you gave me this
opportunity to speak on your behalf
today I am forever grateful and I'm
humbled by your friendship
congratulations to the 2018 embas and
may the force of good be with you
[Applause]
Thank You Rocky
for the em but New York Friday Saturday
class
this year's Executive MBA commitment to
excellence award recipient is jay daya
[Applause]
Jai's primary areas of expertise are
corporate finance mergers and
acquisitions corporate governance
corporate valuation and international
financial markets he's taught finance at
the undergraduate MBA MBA and PhD levels
and is the recipient of several teaching
awards his research has been published
in leading finance journals as well Jay
has served as vice president in the
Capital Markets Group at a top
investment bank and has provided
training and advisory services to
numerous organizations around the world
he is associate professor of Finance at
Baruch College a doctoral faculty member
at CUNY bikini Graduate Center and a
research fellow in finance and economics
at Cambridge University's judge Business
School please join me in congratulating
and welcoming jay daya
[Applause]
I'd like to thank ember 2018 Friday
Saturday for the commitment to
excellence award I was truly surprised
to be selected truly humbled by your
choice and highly value this honor the
decision to select me had me thinking
about how I might define value in my
life in class we talk about value in
assets financial securities companies
our journey for most of us took us from
discussions of how George Costanza and
Kramer from Seinfeld might run haircare
companies through to the complexities of
value in a vineyard when I'm sure we
would have preferred to be sampling the
product but what else can we put a value
on what about family and community every
graduate today as a family or network of
people who have contributed to your
successes many of these people are here
today or around the world celebrating
your achievements with you and I think
it's worth taking a minute to put a
value on their contributions and to
thank them for their input but how can
we attach a monetary value to this let
me use myself as an example although my
immigrant parents weren't educated they
pushed me sometimes unwillingly and
sometimes in the middle of a soccer
match most of you know that's my first
love to appreciate education in their
words loco Tamara Cara visa and a girl
in a lecture kitchen for tomorrow
Saraswathi nahi literally translated
people can take your clothes money home
but they can't take knowledge away from
you my path could have easily led
somewhere different but this value put
me on the road to a PhD that carried me
here today what is the value of my
parents perseverance
how much do I owe them math is something
we use every day in finance both in
industry and academia my brother taught
me math and infused in me a love for
numbers my brother also taught me a how
to fight with him my broken nose his
testament to that but what is the value
of those math skills and love for
numbers how much is it worth in dollars
how much do I owe in moving on to my
oldest sister she obviously couldn't
wait for me to move out her contribution
to my path was teaching me how to look
after myself so I could go out and
explore and experience the world she
taught me how to cook to clean to do
laundry to iron I still use her recipes
she's really a great cook and distain
removing secrets when I'm doing my
laundry today what should she charge me
for this knowledge what is the monetary
value that one would put on that my
argumentative little sister taught me
verbal gymnastics and how to reason I
once tried to teach her how to drive a
car
50 yards into a first lesson she
convinced me that she knew everything
she needed to know so I got out of the
car having learned that her debating
skills were clearly much better than
mine and obviously so were her driving
skills but now I can reason and debate
with you the finest students or should I
say graduates of the world how much do I
owe her for this skill that I use every
day in the classroom with you what about
my extensive community growing up the
librarian Paul who allowed me to take as
many books as I could carry home with me
when the limit was three my teacher mr.
Shannon Coe who would meet me meet me
after school
in his own time to give me learning
problems that would keep me challenged
what is the value of the community that
kept me going through the path that is
led me here today so let's fast forward
today I have two children
who teach me patience humility and how
to make sledding on the coldest day of
the year fun no value can be put on that
and my wife who was scold me and
compassion and caring for others while
letting me believe that I am smarter
than her though I know the truth
she graduated from Columbia there have
been so many contributions from people
in my life that have led me here and to
all of you today and now I consider you
a part of my family I have learned from
you that we all have a story about the
people and communities who have led us
here to the South Lawn in the process we
have laughed argued shed a tear and
learned together you have learned that
finance is not as scary as you may have
once believed many of you with no
background in corporate finance I have
seen grow to understand and appreciate
the inner workings of valuation and its
importance in business and it always
brings me great joy to see I get it now
moment in my students when the light
bulb goes off and to see the completion
of the infamous five hour long bear of
an exam we valued our time together and
it has impacted my path like it has
impacted yours I hope as you probably
have guessed by now
not even your finance professor could
put a monetary value on all the family
and community contributions that make us
who we are today so a word of caution
some of your family and friends sitting
around here today listening to my talk
may want to cash in on their
contributions I suggest that you have
your checkbooks and credit cards at
their ready and a note to family in
France I am available to negotiate a
settlement should you need for a small
fee
on a more serious note enjoy this day
take time to value the contributions of
your own family and community to your
success take the lessons and the
memories from your courses and continue
on your path that has been shaped by so
many while you're at it contribute to
another's if you do this then I will
know I have taught you well
last but not least people now ask me now
that you've won this award what are you
gonna do and on that final note hey kids
we're going to Disney thank you
thanks Jay so it's now my pleasure to
introduce Carolyn dis bra he was
selected by the M Bannu York
friday-saturday class to speak today
Carolyn is the senior director of brand
marketing for CNN worldwide where she
has been employed for almost all of her
16-year career Carolyn has a Bachelor of
Arts degree from University of Virginia
with a concentration in American
government she also holds a Master of
Science degree with a concentration in
broadcast journalism from Columbia
University's Graduate School of
Journalism during her time at CBS
Carolyn traveled to 10 countries and
served as teaching assistants for
several electives
she was community representative for her
cluster and Amba vice president for the
media Management Association
additionally Carolyn audited a number of
classes during the program and if she
were to receive credit for those classes
would now be graduating with more than
six courses worth of extra credit so
please join me in congratulating and
welcoming Carolyn
[Applause]
seven years ago I was in an accident and
I suffered a serious head injury I
recovered but for some time my speech
was slow and labored I often struggled
to find the words I needed to say my
story is not unique in that all of us no
matter what race gender or nationality
have struggled with challenges and
adversity to be here I want to thank the
wonderful classmates from the Friday and
Saturday class of 2018 for the
opportunity to address you today seven
years ago I would never have believed
this moment would be possible I have a
story about adversity camaraderie and
responsibility to tell you it begins
August 26 2016 it was a sweltering
Friday in New York City the Sun rose
that morning at 6:17 a.m. and it set
that night at 7:37 p.m. the temperature
lingered just below a hundred all day
Bitcoin was selling for five hundred and
seventy eight dollars August 26 2016 was
the day we met for the very first time
in a room in room 301 in the building
behind me nervously we gathered at 9
a.m. to begin a journey that forever
changed our lives for you our friends
and families August 25th 2016 marks the
last day you saw us for any substantial
length of time and going forward you
will see more of us we promise indeed
thanks to the copis copious amounts of
food Columbia has fed us the past two
years there is actually more of us to
see than there was on August 26 2016
that first day we were introduced to
each other by Dean Carlson we created
our contracts in our learning teams
pledging to each other to be respectful
to be courteous and to be on
we promise to do all of our homework and
to turn it in early God loves a Trier
professor Paul Ingraham walked us
through our first case tentatively
tentatively we raised our hands and
offered our first answers we soon
discovered the importance of those
learning teams the professor's give you
so much work in Business School you
can't possibly do it alone you have to
work together which is maybe the most
important lesson we learned as
management expert Ken Blanchard said
none of us is as smart as all of us
which is particularly true if you've
never had accounting our first
accounting assignment was supposed to
take two hours and by the way never
believed a professor when they say an
assignment will take you two hours it is
always some multiple of two hours we
spent eighteen hours trying to figure
out non-controlling interest where to
put it on the balance sheet and how to
account for a joint venture we suffered
through back-to-back three-hour lectures
and take-home midterm exams that picked
like a bomb turn it counting down the
minutes until you had to turn in your
spreadsheet with every conceivable
answer you could pull out of thin air in
a desperate attempt for a high pass
every so often someone would point out
the fact that we voluntarily signed up
for this and we were paying a lot of
money to be here and then there were the
finals do you remember that moment we
walked into Watson library in the
business school building to study we
looked at each other we thought so we
found the club but does anybody know
where the library is the social
networking and Watson library is so loud
it is truly futile to try to study there
you only go there to party between
classes since we partied in the library
we had to study everywhere but there for
finals we studied on planes on trains in
our offices during lunch breaks and of
course every hour of every weekend
everyone had their own personal strategy
for taking finals some of us sat in the
same seat in the same room for every
test never straying from routine in the
hopes of a miracle
some of us carb loaded some of us waited
until the night before to learn all of
the material aced the exam and ruined
the curve for the rest of us it wasn't
all work we travelled the world together
as a matter of fact if we were doing
anything we were doing it together if we
were running marathons if we were
starting companies if we were eating
studying hiking working drinking napping
we were doing it together mostly we
created opportunities for each other to
succeed comedian Amy Poehler said find a
group of people who challenge and
inspire you spend a lot of time with
them and it will change your life my
standing here is an example of what my
classmates have done for me today may 12
2008 een is our final lecture the Sun
rose at 5:42 a.m. and it will set at
8:03 p.m. tonight and just like August
26 2016 something new begins today the
topic of our final lecture centers on
how do we
the responsibility born of this great
opportunity to change the world Columbia
has given us more than a degree it has
provided us the potential to be leaders
with a concurrent responsibility to be
of service this is our greatest
assignment together we all move forward
from this lawn forever better forever
changed and all of us possessed of an
opportunity that Hemingway captured so
beautifully in saying there is nothing
Noble in being superior to your fellow
man true nobility is being superior to
your former self
our time at Columbia has made this
possible ladies and gentlemen the class
of 2018 has already accepted the
challenge and responsibility to change
the world
6% of the CEOs of Fortune 500 companies
are women 20% of the members of the
United States Congress are women yet 100
percent of today's students speakers are
women
[Applause]
beginning today with our families who
have loved us created us and supported
us together we show the responsibility
and the power to improve our lives and
the lives of those around us to speak
for those who are silent and to take
immutable broken circumstances and fix
them there will always be challenges
nothing is easy and nothing is given but
how can we be anything other than
exuberantly hopeful but how can we be
anything other than exuberantly hopeful
given the extraordinary people gathered
here today let me be very clear these
are the people who will make all of our
tomorrows brighter thank you to the
professors in the administration of
Columbia Business School thank you to
our friends and families and finally
congratulations and thank you to the
wonderful men and women of Columbia
Business School class of 2018
[Applause]
it is now my honor to introduce today's
commencement speaker the world rightly
knows John Martin is a highly successful
media executive mr. Martin is the
chairman and chief executive officer of
Turner a global portfolio of media
brands including CNN HLN TBS TNT
bleacher report Turner Classic Movies
Adult Swim and the Cartoon Network he
stands at the helm of one of the world's
largest media companies at a moment when
many are wondering about the future of
what has been historically called
television John has led Turner on a
mission to reimagine television
transforming every part of Turner's
business by focusing the company and its
brands on being one of the largest
creators and acquirers
of original content delivering unique
audience experiences fueled by
innovative technology and data-driven
insights he doesn't just embrace change
he runs with it prior to assuming his
current position in 2014
Jon served as Time Warner's chief
financial and administration
administrative officer it's somewhat
it's somewhat unusual for someone with a
background in finance by profession John
is a CPA to emerge as a media innovator
but John Martin is just that he talks
about his company in terms of content
and in terms of distribution but he is
just as quick to say he wants Turner to
be a place where people enjoy working
this is the mark of a true leader
because whether it's the consumer we
cannot see or the employer-employee we
may not know without these stakeholders
being well served we cannot succeed in
business john's academic grounding is
rigorous he received his bachelor's
degree in economics from Wharton and his
MBA with a concentration in finance and
organizational behavior right here at
Columbia he serves on the Board of
Overseers of Columbia Business School as
well as the board of the Paley Center
for Media that is how the wider world
knows John Martin I know John Martin as
a dedicated mentor and champion for his
employees John was the first person at
the company I told of my interest in
applying to CBS he was immediately
encouraging supportive and generous with
his advice I want to therefore use this
platform not only to personally thank
him
for all he's done for me but for also
the many other employees at Turner and
Time Warner that he has coached
throughout the years
Dean's classmates and honored guests
please join me in welcoming a global
business leader a mentor and a true
friend to Columbia Business School mr.
John Martin
[Applause]
Wow Carolyn congratulations I'm proud of
you amazing congratulations to all of
you two things before I even start
number one how do you know what time the
Sun came up this morning there was no
Sun and the second thing and to my
professor my colleague my friend Dean
Hubbard when Carolyn was introducing me
he looks over me goes fake news thank
you sir it's awesome
so Thank You Carolyn Dean Hubbard
distinguished faculty members of the
administration proud parents you should
be proud and of course to you the most
important people here today the
graduates congratulations please accept
my sincere congratulations it's an honor
and a privilege to be with you this
morning and I am humbled by the
invitation to speak with you and I
apologize for my voice I'm having a
little bit of a allergy attack New York
City style so I'm gonna try to get
through this but as I thought about what
to say this morning's I've never done
this before this is actually a little
daunting so bear with me
I went basically what everybody does I
went to YouTube and I watched 25
commencement addresses and most of them
sucked some were inspirational some were
funny and some were informative and some
were really just good in general but you
know what when I got done with the 25th
one I said none of them is even remotely
like relevant to my life and so if
you're gonna ask me to come here and
speak this morning I'm actually going to
tell you about my story so you got to
bear with me here my professional
journey began in 1994 when I graduated
from the Columbia Business School and it
was an honor and a privilege to be here
and just bear with me for just this is
going to take just a few minutes but
what really struck me is the world that
you're now advancing into in your
business career versus the world when I
was in 1994 I mean the Dow was less than
4,000 the interest rate was eight and a
half percent think about that eight and
a half percent versus now where we
almost have no interest on the global
front Bill Clinton and Boris Yeltsin
signed the Kremlin papers effectively
ending a decade of long nuclear threat
between Russia and America our love
affair with Russia continues
Nelson Mandela was elected president of
South Africa Serbia was attacking Bosnia
tensions were growing around the nuclear
threat of North Korea well that hasn't
changed the first Gulf War ended and no
one ever used the word terrorism think
about that on the top front netscape
launched its web browser quickly became
the market leader and to be clear this
was not the instantaneous and mobile web
experience we enjoy today but rather a
terribly slow process of staring at a
rotating ball and hoping that your
dial-up connection worked even so I'm
proud to say that I was part of the
first class at Columbia Business School
that allowed laptops in the classroom
and they were terrible mark zuckerberg
was 10 Kurt Cobain was found dead Oh ga
was driving a white Bronco and one of
the most popular TV shows in the United
States was beavis and butt-head proving
that even then there was hope for
America's youth I was married and in my
spare time I played soccer also which is
my passion and my love but I was in the
process of Sun setting a really bad
mullet haircut and and I was thankful
for that and I anticipate that similar
to how you all feel today I had a lot of
enthusiasm graduating from the Columbia
Business School but also some
trepidation about how am I going to take
this world class amazing educational
experience that I received and actually
apply it in the real world so how did I
get here I was at dinner two years ago
with a college friend of mine from when
I went to Penn and he referred to me as
the quote unquote accidental CEO and I
looked at him and I said what do you
mean and he said I don't mean any
respect but of all the people that we
went to school with the pen you were the
last person we expected to succeed oddly
enough I didn't take any disrespect with
that and why is that well I grew up on
Long Island the son of two hard-working
parents neither of whom went to college
my dad was a Navy veteran he owned a car
Bell ice cream store so I was the most
well fed I screamed kid of anybody that
on that I knew on Long Island he owned
it for 13 years and for 13 years he took
three days off a year on Thanksgiving
Christmas Day and New Year's Day he
worked 362 how many days are there three
and sixty-two 363 in a leap year he
worked 362 days a year and he never
complained he had to do it because he
had to provide for our family and I
learned my work ethic from watching my
father day in and day out my mother
worked part-time with him but she always
had time for myself and my two older
sisters and she always had a kind word a
great sense of humor and everybody that
knew her loved her a lot I inspire to
emulate her kindness and her humility
and everything that I do so I got good
grades in high school we all did I
graduated second in my high school class
and I was accepted to Wharton to be
honest none of my peers or teachers in
my high school believed that I was Ivy
League material and several of them
tried to talk me out of going to Wharton
because they thought I would fail out
and the more that they told me that I
was going to fail the more I wanted to
prove them wrong and the more I wanted
to succeed so I went to Wharton and I
focused most of my energy on playing
soccer and attending parties
like my grades were good but not great
but if you included a component of my
grades of party attendance I would have
graduated summa laude so upon
graduating I went to go work at Ernst I
have no idea what the hell I wanted to
do so I went into the accounting
profession I went to go your work at
Ernst & Young I stayed there for you few
years and then I came to the Columbia
Business School and I came here to get a
diploma and instead I got an education
and while everyone's journey is
different I want to share with you five
beliefs that have helped me as I've done
my own journey through my career first
in my congratulations to you on
graduating be prepared to work hard work
very hard you're already doing it you're
already accomplished you're already
highly intelligent but the competitive
landscape is not getting any easier I
don't have to tell you that and even the
most gifted people have to work really
hard prodigies are like unicorns they
don't exist hard work gets you to
advancement together with working hard
don't ever give up you'll rarely achieve
anything you want in the first try in
fact failure is a critical component of
any success story and don't let anyone
tell you that you can't do something
don't accept the status quo in fact be
fearful of the status quo I've seen more
change in business in the last four
years than I've seen in the previous 15
years it's both energizing and
terrifying set ambitious goals and it'll
keep you motivated second find a mentor
actively seek out a mentor it changed my
professional career
I ran investor relations beginning in
2002 I worked for a gentleman by the
name of dick Parsons he was the chairman
and CEO of Time Warner he then went on
to become the chairman of Citigroup and
he's done any a number of things
including running the LA Clippers for a
year which was probably everybody's
dream he changed my life he somehow took
a liking to me and to this day I still
don't know why but from a career
standpoint he made all the difference in
the world to me and he's still an
incredible friend and a colleague and
actively seek out a mentor we all need
people who are going to be champions of
us and so I would encourage you to take
advantage of whatever resources are
available for you third find your inner
EQ you all have high IQ you're all
sitting here graduating from the
Columbia Business School with an MBA
degree but how many people know people
that are terrible to be around and work
with you know it's it's all about me I
did this great you suck the people truly
in life that you want to work with are
those people that have not only a high
IQ but more importantly a high EQ so
what I tried to do from my mom is I try
to channel her kindness her generosity
her graciousness her humbleness and it
has really served me well in my career
and I may never have another success in
business again but I've gotten to this
place in part because I've extended a
level of graciousness to people that
they've really appreciated and they've
reciprocated and I think that's
incredibly important and there's so many
smart people in this world that just
missed that and be the type of colleague
that people want to work with I think
it's invaluable fourth find and nurture
diverse teams you've probably
experienced that a lot I mean as Dean
Hubbard said and others have commented
you're all incredibly diverse with
backgrounds and different experiences
and that's great
continue to seek that out as you go
through your career encourage diversity
of opinion and please accept views that
are inconsistent with your own fight
against your own insecurities and if
you're in a position of leadership make
sure the people around you feel safe to
offer a dissenting opinion my boss the
chairman and CEO of Time Warner requires
in any meeting where there's a material
decision that's going to get made there
has to at least be one person in the
room who disagrees with a recommendation
Jesus what this thing is crazy
and and there's it's like a plant it's
like okay that seat is for the
dissenting opinion but what he does then
is then he'll explore that person's
dissenting opinion why they don't agree
with the rest of the group and through
the process of discipline debate you
inevitably always wind up making better
decisions I mean it's one of the most
amazing things I've learned from him and
so search to surround yourself with
people who are not just gonna tell you
yes surround yourself with people that
are going to give you a hard time and
fifth and this is most important hope
for a little luck sometime along the way
with your journey I've had numerous
pivotal moments in my life where I've
I've gotten a promotion or I gained
additional responsibility only because
I've been at the right place at the
right time I have worked with so many
talented executives and sometimes being
in the right place at the right time
I've been lucky and I'm thankful for it
and so I can probably credit the last
four promotions too just the mere fact
that either somebody retired they moved
over they got promoted and I was in the
right place at the right time so I wish
you as much luck as I've had in my own
professional career so as you sit here
today I encourage all of you to figure
out how you wanted to find your own
journey and your success the path to
success is always under construction
you're all starting off with the gift of
intelligence you wouldn't be here if you
didn't but intelligence alone doesn't
mean that you're gonna succeed like I
said it's it's some cocktail or
combination of all these other things
that are gonna help you all along your
way and I read recently that Millennials
are looking at companies that have a
noble purpose the World Economic Forum
found that a sense of purpose in work is
the second most important characteristic
of a company second only to salary all
of the most powerful movements in
popular culture whether if you think in
music whether it was Punk or hip-hop or
things of a much higher order such as
civil rights all come from a place of
having a noble purpose I'm in a business
that manages powerful brands that
influences popular culture from kids to
entertainment to sports to news and
brands are more than just you know a
combination of purchases and I lost my
last page of the script holy all
right I found it relax I got it I got it
I scared you right
brands are more than just an aggregation
of products of people buying and selling
them but brands should stand for
something and if we fulfill the noble
purpose of Turner then it should enable
us to deliver a game-changing rallying
cry which is going to make our business
even more successful so today noble
purpose is really driven by two macro
factors macro drivers first economic
abundance and second unprecedented
connectivity now those sound great
economic abundance unprecedented
connectivity but both come at a cost so
last year the SP closed at a record high
was a fantastic year for economic
abundance in many countries but in many
societies there's a phenomenon being
described of the normalization of
loneliness
the US Surgeon General has described
loneliness as an epidemic and since the
1960s single person households have
doubled here in the United States to
represent 30 percent today which is a
staggering number because of this
culture of detachment the UK just named
a minister of loneliness to combat the
social norms that are happening around
the world our naturist people were pack
animals we gather in herds we have
family we have friends we want a sense
of security and we want to be loved and
accepted and appreciated by others the
consequence of ambition though striving
in your career is by definition going to
push you in the direction of loneliness
so I mention that only because I hope
that you'll push against that to be
alone it's leading to a breakdown in our
social norms and our society in general
and with respect to I'm bringing the
good weather this is great
and with respect to unprecedented
unprecedented connectivity and my two
children are here today and I love them
and I'm so proud of them but they are
definition of connectivity in fact that
you guys are probably on your phones
right now a day without Wi-Fi in my home
is Armageddon
if Alexa doesn't speak to us we feel
rejected so our ability to connect on a
global scale whenever we want is one of
our greatest technological advances in
the last century but this Kennet
connectivity is ironically leading to a
culture of detachment how many of you
have entered into a relationship or
exited a relationship via text or by a
facebook messenger or via snapchat
I said to my daughter once when she
ended a relationship I said did you not
think the call on the phone she's like
who would do that I would ask you to
fight against these phenomenon why
because this world needs leaders
business leaders political leaders
philanthropists and so on and a Turner
we occurred belonging through what we
call fandom understanding the power of
connectivity we merge science and
creativity to galvanize audiences to
become communities of fans to share
their passions and experiences so please
find your fandom find your passions find
your voice don't compromise who you are
as individuals use that power of
connectivity to be able to affect the
world in ways that nobody could have
imagined when I graduated from the
Columbia Business School in 1994 be
involved stay educated believe it or not
this is not the end of your education
we're all still learning stay involved
stay educated become active take the
eagerness that you feel today and use it
to help shape the world in the future we
need you so please accept my humble
congratulations I'm proud of all of you
and I wish you only the best in the
future thank you
[Applause]
build congratulations to the three amber
classes of 2018 it is so nice to see
personal former students under the tent
I am very proud that your achievements
congratulations also to my colleagues
Donna Paul and J for receiving the
commitment for excellence a world so
well deserved five years ago the Ember
class of 2013
bestowed the commitment for Excellence
Award to Professor Naju Mohammad who
received it in person
the following year the Ember class of
bestowed the commitment for excellence
award again to Professor 'innahu melamed
unfortunately now whom could not
personally accept the prize as he passed
earlier in the year
his wife Maya and daughter Cherie who is
with me today accepted the prize on his
behalf
she is actually stepping into her
father's big shoes
she graduated from Columbia Business
School last year with a PhD in marketing
and now is an assistant professor of
marketing at Wharton professor Naju
melamed
[Applause]
boface Onuaku melamed was a gifted
scholar amazing teacher and beloved
friend for everyone
he was my personal mentor for almost 30
years after her his in tun timely passed
passing we wanted to ensure that his
memory stays with us and with the school
forever we also wanted to capture
neroon's unique personality and
qualities into his memorial two things
came to mind now who was the best at
everything he did Anna whom had a great
passion for teaching in particular in
ember so his friends in the accounting
division initiated the nation' de Mello
mod memorial award the highest honor
given at the recognition ceremony to a
graduating students from each class in
the Executive MBA program the recipients
have demonstrated exceptional academic
skills as well as a significant impact
on the Columbia community each of
today's three awardees will receive a
bond above and beyond the Big O no a
check in the amount of $2,000 this is
the fifth time we are honoring the Naju
maluma the world the recipient for the
ember New York Saturday class is Kyle
Moen
[Applause]
the recipient from the my America class
is dagger Yeltsin
[Applause]
and the recipient from the Ember New
York for the Saturday class is Katelyn
Lyon
[Applause]
thank you and congratulations to all of
you
[Applause]
students who demonstrate exceptional
academic performance in the top 5% of
their class graduate with Dean's honors
with distinction as I call your names
please stand to be recognized the
following students will graduate with
Dean's honors with distinction for the M
Bannu York Saturday class Thomas D
Arminio Juan Herrera
Kyle Moran Gillian Robbins Bowie shamsky
and Jackson Tanis the following students
will graduate with Dean's honors with
distinction from the embas class dagger
edge Olsen and Joe Schwartz
wait a second I think I'm missing one
okay sorry all right following students
will graduate with Dean's honors with
distinction for the M by New York Friday
Saturday class Jonathon gold
Nick Graff
Ilya a vodka
[Applause]
daniela shot lush chance gull ruas Dogen
kathleen Reaume Sara Walter
[Applause]
I just couldn't stop without confirming
that so congratulations to all of you
for this very large book for this very
big accomplishments the Ethan our
Henneberry Student Representative Awards
are presented to the electic academic
cluster career honor board women in
business and Executive Board student
representatives to recognize their
dedication to serving the interests of
their classmates and to the overall
betterment of the executive mba program
the dean's office has named these awards
for ethan Hannah berry who successfully
led the schools
EMBO programs as well as other critical
areas of the school before his
retirement in 2011 as I read each of
your names please stand at your place so
that we may recognize you the
representatives for the MBA New York
Saturday class are rich M singer
Danielle Ben ado che and Sophie Carter
ng joy
Dayna Greenbaum
Elliott Heston
William Irvine Michael Loretta Steven
Norman and Laura Lauren bacon the
representatives for the Emma America's
class our Courtney Burnaby Brittany
Johnson Isaac musica Tessa Nate little
would Alexandra quarrels Arabiya capital
Shroff michael southern and jonathan web
the representatives for the mbone New
York Friday Saturday class our Gil Adler
Edwina bright Miranda Chu Nicole Clark
Carolyn dis brow Stephen Gilman
Catherine Griggs Eliza Johnston Rachel
kovarsky Daniella shots and Kathleen
Rome again everyone please join me in
thanking each of these representatives
for their outstanding contributions to
the end the community
[Applause]
the Executive MBA distinguished service
award is presented to a graduating
student from each cluster selected by
classmates as deserving special
recognition for contributions to the
class spirit and experience the
recipient for the Ember New York
Saturday class is Richard am singer
[Applause]
so each class elects a Distinguished
Service Award just to clarify the
recipient for the MBA America's class is
Nathan little wood Nate little wood
[Applause]
the recipients it was a tie for the M
Bini York Friday Saturday class are
Edwina bright and and Carolyn dis prowl
[Applause]
okay the names of our graduating
students will now be read by Felicia
Goodman its kovitch director of student
and academic affairs and Declan Carroll
Director of Ember global and inba
marecus as difficult as it is we ask
that the audience remain seated and hold
your applause throughout the entire
reading so that all names may be heard
we will now read the names of the
graduates of the M Bannu York Saturday
class of 2018
Diana Acosta Christian Adame Alexander
akula's Anthony Albanese dan ambrosia
Richard and singer haseen Azari Lisa
Baker a budget bhasu Danielle Lauren
been adieu che Carolyn
Butler and Sophie cart Ray Allen cherien
Mason Czeslaw Jessica cho in G choy
Pamela Cory Katie
kalenna Thomas G Arminio Marshawn Dean
Jennifer Doyle up a a dune Karen SP
Jordan frein Sarah Goering Daniel Paul
Girardi gen Lee Gong rocky grana Han
Deena
Greenbaum Jessie Greenberg Philippe
guima res Teresa ha Gavin Moya
Eric Campbell Harmon
Bessie on Hasani Elliot has done Owen he
v1 Herrera June here on Oh Francis Wang
Jessica
broy Hutton Simone Lewis eloah Bill
Irvine Karthik Iyengar David Jacobson
Kelly Joyce Arun kalyanasundaram Brooks
Ashton can ski Kumar Khanna melee
Shannon Kara Ryan
Andrew Kassabian a thief taja
Nishant Khatri poor V kundru Avinash
Quatro Calvert lang
Nicholas leisure Julie Lee Josh Levitch
James Lee Gary Lee Craig liebe Michael
Loretta
Brian Mahoney at Ola
Malik Ashish Manchanda Alexandra Alana
man coming now
Maureen McMahon Richard miles
John Huff milord
Shan cool metal Kyle Moran gig Morris
David mote Salone say Danielle owner
Rove bin Jack me Jay Nicholas Steve
Norman
Michael scene Orson
Benjamin nunnery Kelly Meredith
O'Connell Tosun or lopata
Lauren bacon Deena Panzer Steven pack
[Applause]
Virginia Milano para Nelly Aaron Michel
Perry jockey piccolo Emanuel pick lock
on kita prahara Philip poon Kathryn
relly Nathan Whittlesey Riggs Gillian
Robbins fish Shahu our roof Sankar
Meghna sir off Kurt Ryan Schwab Shelby
swab our ally second Shiv say T G
Robshaw
re Shan ski Samuel Shevat you way she
Anthony she Andrew Jonathan show head
David Ryan Talbot Jackson Tannis James
Tribble
Roenick Trivedi georgette SATs Alice
Daniel vigor Ito iris wang wesley wu e
yang bill gay Elmas Kenichi Yoshioka
we will now read the names of the
graduates of the MB America's class of
Inigo Barca is staggie oom it'd be sane
Courtney Burnaby Alex Buckley Mario
Castro Courtney denise dorn el dagger a
Jolson Malvika
Goswami Brittany Johnson
[Applause]
Landon Johnson Nina beam to kata dr.
David Kim Isaac
Malaysia katisa Nate Littlewood John
Higgins McDonald Ricardo Marchand Brenda
Elena
Martinez guajardo Zack Medallia Roger
Milford Raphael Navas Jason Nelson
Gustavo plank
[Applause]
Alexandra Quarles
reveille a go Amanda Raposo
Alicia Samaniego K Sean burger Joe
Schwartz Barrett's Scruggs dr. Kapil or
Shroff Luis si las Monique Kathleen sofa
Tanya and Nicole trim eater
Tiffany Christina
say yon Wang
Jonathan Hudson web
two O's young beyond June June
we will now read the names of the
graduates of the M Bannu York Friday
Saturday class of 2018
Kent MD Abdullah Gil Adler Priya
Erin Damien Altaf Jeffrey Anderson Vic
batch pie Alessandra Baker
[Applause]
Sasha Belle Muir day ha bunsall Joshua
Vincent Barlow Peter Bogart carmine
Amato Berardi J Bank Aria songket bomani
Joanne Faustina Viscardi Thomas Bradford
Edwina bright Edward Alan brown shave
Buckner
Raphael car Mago Lopez aundrea car
Donnie McPherson Carroll shitty Shaba
lake chalen Miranda Cheechoo Andrew
Ciolino Nicole Clark
Ryan Coelho Phil Kosta Eric Thomas court
Ryan William Cunningham hate we de motor
Kunal and Desai
Carolyn je dis brow Kendall doable
Andrew Duff it Lansford Dyer me Kyle
Edouard Abigail Fisher Ryan Fischer
Brittany Flynn cliff Gerber Stephen
Gilman Rohit Geary
Jonathan gold
Ryan Gonzales Kasey goth Nick Groff been
grants hailey M grant Katherine Griffin
Katherine Gregg's
pranaam Gupta rupak Gupta
Christopher Hardy Alan ho
Jeremy Hopkins Chris Q thir Diana Huang
Ramiro Iglesias Oh sir chiku Amaka II
came a funa tarik afife Ilya Ilya a
vasco's a crotchy Johari Eliza Johnston
Brooke Jones Chinetti Julian Joseph
Andrew Khan
Sandhya Kasturi Harrison W cats
Robert kine Emily kipping Kyle Kirk
Nathan coy Rachel course key min-jeong
Irene Kwok Danielle LaChance
Matthew Patrick Lumumba andreas Michael
LAN John Timothy Landers Andrew Lane
Steven la perla Brandon Lee Thomas
Lombardi le Lots Michael Leuven
Christopher Macy's Armel manga James
Mangini
James Martin Ryan McMahon Jeffrey
Mercato Adam matoro monk Mishra Linnea
month II shun Suki
Murakami Victoria Elizabeth Myers
Mostafa Muhammed Noguchi buddy she and
Jerry Charles a kochu karu oz Dogen
Darrin person
Amy picking itch Gabriel Gabriel Peeta
mark Pollock Johnson Cheon Deepa
Rajamani nathie Raj Kapoor
Larissa around Genie love Rosalyn Aarthi
Ravi Kumar
Kathleen Reaume David Reed Simon able
Rio Alberto Salazar
Gabriel Serrano Susana Shaw Meredith
shields Zachary Sheriff Lenny Singh and
Peter Becker Smith Joey spits Lauren
Steinberg Lauren Sumner Leon yurevic
site shoe ski James Tanis
Elena Cho sati Jeff true Giglio Tonya
van der Woude rojan Vaz irani roubini 3
villain and Bryan wing Sara Walter Kim
Lee Wong Jason right Elaine whoo
Martin Zahara off
Lisa Lindsay
zing please join us in applauding the
graduates
okay now I realize that I am the only
thing standing between you and a
well-deserved time and reception with
your families and of course the rain has
stopped a little so I'll I'll be I'll be
brief
you all have achieved something
incredibly special but no doubt either
on the way here today or sometime
recently somebody said well you know
that thing you want to do it is probably
not a good time for that my parting
message for you is that you should never
believe it when somebody says that I'll
close with a little story some years ago
when I worked in the government I was in
Japan negotiating a trade agreement it's
called the trans-pacific partnership
perhaps you've heard of it we're still
working on it I came back to the United
States with my Japanese colleague taka
nachus on we got in a taxi at Dulles
field we're going to the capital and we
passed the National Archives on which is
written past his prologue and my
Japanese colleague turned to me and said
what does that really mean
and I launched into one of my
long-winded college professor II kind of
discussions and the cab driver lost it
and turned around he said what this guy
is trying to say to you is you ain't
seen nothing yet that's my message for
you congratulations graduates now
for everyone's benefit the graduates and
we will all be filing out so if you
could remain in your seats and then
follow them you can also follow us all
as we head to Ansel Plaza for the
reception congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
once again ladies and gentlemen please
allow the graduates to exit before
exiting the guest tents thank you
[Music]
[Applause]